hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys in
salamander today we're checking our
trailer for a wolf barrel Kristin
Kristin Kristin Wiig movie a lifetime
called a deadly adoption this is only a
20 second teaser they released yeah but
let's see if this is worth watching yes
or funny because it's on lifetime that
is wolf arrow and kristen wiig's have no
idea what this is
selfish coward liar we do our strange
girl all right that was super short I
but in terms of toning style I feel like
this is a serious no it's a parody it
how was it be parody deadly adoption and
she's standing there with a gun and he's
all like uh to be serious oh let me jump
out it's a lifetime movie what they like
it's kristen wiig eager and welfare
although like it has to be a joke I
cannot take this Susan well Will Ferrell
and Kristen Wiig have done dramas apart
from eating this one and they proven
they can do promise I wouldn't be
surprised if it cuz you know lifetime is
just known for doing like shitty drama
so yeah the murderous stories this is
just too much like you just seem Will
Ferrell and Kristen Wiig in it like it's
a distraction team to wonder if this
movies about an adoption it turned
deadly I mean I kind of like other doing
this like just a 20-second tease and you
see Will Ferrell and Kristen Wiig and
they're promoting it like a serious
drama because yeah the big payoff could
be that it's a spoof it's gotta be a
success on the poster for it and I
laughed and what was the poster
consisted of just like up the deadly
adoption it looks like a pretty serious
photo to me it looks funny I don't know
I mean it looks like a 1970s drama but
yeah that phase like it's just we'll
Pharaoh you're just I think you just
associated Will Ferrell was funny did so
you're gonna find it funny it's totally
a parity i will bet you chipotle it is a
parody when this movie comes out you owe
me chipotle okay i'll buy you chipotle
but it doesn't look funny to me super
but I hope it's a deceitful trailer
because I would enjoy it more if it's a
comedy yeah especially from lifetime
because life doesn't really do fun he
doesn't make sense to me I mean like I
could see the going out to pass like
will ferrell and Kristen way can't
really do dramas because they're so
known in the comedy world so they would
go to something small like lifetime
where they could do drama or they're
just doing a spoof of lifetime dramas
lifetime actually agreed to it yeah it
could be one of the two would be epic no
it could be and it could be cuz will
ferrell like does a lot of things on the
side that we never hear about but then
you find out that he's like doing stuff
for Funny or Die or some random comedy
thing maybe this is gonna be good who
knows but I want to see another trailer
that's for sure no anyway guys thanks
for tuning in to the real rejects if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out salamander Sally's channel are
you yawning in the middle of my
monologue during the outro check out her
channel salamander Sally evolves on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine
where if we get enough followers we can
get more product placement jayden des
roar Sears de cero cero Amen can I get a
shout-out I've been watching your vids
for a while now and I love them they
always make me smile and I love your
jokes PS i believe you'll make it very
far in the entertainment business and
become famous worldwide extra PS tell
Veronica I say hola amigo why you want
to [ __ ] my girlfriend is that it you
want to [ __ ] my girlfriend can't [ __ ] my
girlfriend well let's see what you look
like Pass you should check my instagram
out because I'm a unicorn it's on a
unicorn 77 I'm yes son j/k I'm your dad
JK i'm a turtle PS you will be on the
conan show i know bro Jaden dis Roasters
it sounds like you have a condition he's
a unicorn a unicorn like a real unicorn
yeah look he doesn't have a profile
picture unicorns can't upload program
fiction but anyway Jaden happy shout out
to you I'm glad that we make you laugh
and hopefully um hopefully Hercules
rides you will
visit unicorn you ready okay kisses damn
it Jaden listen man if you want my
girlfriend for the night I'll see what I
can arrange okay what if I want her for
the night you can have her for free
you're my friend mr. did you Yassir
nervous cuz your best have sex with
Veronica as long as I'm in the room it's
okay is this a serious thing